[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting I'm gonna tell you a story
I want to take your it's a true story I
want to take you on a journey a chain of
events that began in the wake of episode
before last
our first memories episode yep
you remember that right I've already
forgotten it well I you know the story
I'm gonna tell it's a story of
confrontation pain forgiveness and the
power of words you really set it up and
it's also the story specifically of one
word one very special word it's been a
wild ride over the last couple of weeks
and I just got to a point I was like I
have to share what has happened maybe
this won't be as sensational as
groundbreaking anybody else but me
talking about it in that tone yeah I
think it will be sensational just
because I'm sensationalizing it but it I
don't know if it requires that I don't
yeah I don't think it requires that I
will say that it's it's just been
something that's been deeply meaningful
to me and I think it's shaped Who I am
as a person it's directly related to
this podcast Wow and does it have to be
that deep order for it to be worthy of
the podcast it's okay that's fair well
it it has shaped how I conduct myself on
this podcast moving forward it's a wild
ride I'm making on word of that but it
has an unexpected double happy ending by
show of hands who's ready for a double
happy ending
I don't know if I can handle that you
shouldn't have actually raised your
hands because that's kind of weird kind
of awkward before we get into link story
- do you want a double happy ending
today nope I don't believe in Happy
Endings I don't go to those kinds of
places you tell my like fairy tales
the first thing I want to do is I want
to let you know that the mythical
kitchen has launched its own podcast
called a hot dog is a sandwich and it is
a weekly podcast that comes out every
Wednesday I'm so I'm so excited for him
we're Josh and Nicole will debate a
controversial food topic now one of the
things that we noticed about Josh early
on when he started working here yep was
I mean you've seen him demonstrate this
on good mythical morning in a mythical
kitchen dudas a food encyclopedia but
he's not just an encyclopedia because an
encyclopedia presents just facts no Josh
goes above facts and starts inserting
his home very well-formed well reasoned
opinions about food which is well err a
subjective thing to be I mean we're
having like a party I'm like a mythical
entertainment party people can I see
that I see that there was like a crowd
of people over there and they were all
around Josh just grilling him about food
questions in it and so I went over there
and just got a kick out of just
listening in on it so we you know I the
podcast wasn't our idea but I'm very
excited that now you have the
opportunity how the same experience that
we have at our mythical get-togethers
and then let's see what the first
episode one the cult no Nicole is there
to balance him I don't know I don't know
exactly what may I hope balance first
keep him in check first episode they're
arguing about whether or not pineapple
belongs on pizza which is a
controversial thing it's already out
wherever you listen apart wherever you
if you're listening to this you can also
listen to that and then a portion of the
podcast and video form will come out the
day after all in the mythical ethical
kitchen YouTube channel so check it out
check it out y'all check daddy I have a
little something that happened to me
this morning but I think I need to just
get out there sensationalize it might
change your life don't think is it a
story forgiveness in the power of words
no it's just a fun little story link all
right
oh come the bar can be low first my wife
my wife is out of town okay
she's hanging out with friends explains
why your
like a children's entertained right
exactly and she's well first of all my
wife doesn't dress me yes she's she
doesn't lay my clothes out anymore it is
funny because this morning Christy
happened to be standing in the closet
when I was also in the closet picking
out my clothes and I was like Christy I
want you to pick out what I'm gonna wear
today weird that's weird this is it no
once I got here Keiko said they wanted
me to wear merch so I had to change
clothes okay this is not what what about
the outerwear
I changed the jacket cuz it didn't what
about the jeans you had a story to tell
um so she's out of town so you know the
McLaughlin household is hanging on by
thread the kids I think they're being
fed I'm pretty sure I have seen some
like crumbs in the kitchen I pretty I
doubt that they're bathing but that's
not my responsibility and so of course
my wife I I have to take them to school
and not every day nah I don't have to
pick them up every day but I was it
taken to school every day while she's
going and first of all just shout out to
the parents who have to take their kids
to school and pick them up and take them
everywhere I think you should unionize
because just after doing this just for a
couple of days which I'm not saying I've
never taken five kids to school but like
when my wife is not there and so I've
got to kind of be responsible for
getting them up and making sure they're
ready and everybody getting ready to go
out the door and then also take them and
then you know what my wife has to do is
she's got to pick them up but then also
take them to all the other crafts that
they got to do and I just really feel
like there should be a union I mean if
the taxi drivers can unionize why can't
the parental drivers unionize because
they need they got rights think they
have to have some rights like like what
like the right to play the music that
they want to play now that the kids want
to play oh the right to keep the kids
from eating crummy foods in the back of
the car the right to keep the kids from
leaving their freaking
belongings in the car okay those kinds
of things I think it's also the right to
insist that the kids respond when the
parent asks how was your day
yeah but you're actually going to give a
thoughtful response why are you talking
like that and it can lead to a
conversation parents unite but this
morning was more difficult than usual
because as you know I recently got solar
panels put on the top of my house so
that I can go totally solar go off the
grid disconnect which is technically
illegal I've learned you can't
disconnect from the grid so I'm still on
the grid but now I'm giving power back
to the Power Company
I don't know if solar panels are weird
but I'm glad we have them but today was
the day that they were gonna be turned
on Oh
after they pass and sounds like a big
moment where nothing perceptible happens
right
especially when it's cloudy but my wife
calls me last night and says oh you can
call her Jessi no one has a name no I
can't she said I couldn't okay just
kidding
Jessi called me and said oh the they're
gonna cut the solar panels on tomorrow
and the inspectors gonna be there and
the guy from the solar company told me
that occasionally the inspector will ask
to go inside the house to inspect your
smoke detectors okay okay well I went on
I went on the Internet's
I looked up like California regulations
about smoke detectors I assumed just
based on what I've learned about living
in California that they they require
like a smoke detector in every room a
smoke detector tied around the neck of
every person to smoke detectors on your
pets one smoke detector on the aquarium
for your fish and seven smoke detectors
on top of your house and every there's a
lot of regulations needs to have a
sticker that says this is not all smoke
detector process information contains
materials which are known to the state
of California to contain
Sinjin yet and not only it which I got
away but kill you everything in
California has this sticker on it you
walk into a building there's like a
plaque right you open the door to your
car there's a sticker on your car that
says anywhere you look this so-and-so
has materials known by the to the state
of California to cause cancer yeah so
anyway I was like well I don't know if
we got into smoke detectors we got one
in all the bedrooms but there's really
like since we like redid the kitchen and
some say I think we got rid of some
downstairs so I I installed first of all
smoke detectors technology oh gosh it's
updated since last time I looked into it
no longer there's that they don't come
with a battery or they they come with a
special kind of battery that never
requires you to change it for years and
you don't have to put regular batteries
in there you just take the thing out and
activate it like press a button flip a
little switch and then it's good to go
so of course we were we had dinner last
night with a friend so we were out late
and so I didn't install it last night oh
so I was like I'll do it in the morning
before I take the kids to school and
then you know I kind of got up late they
kind of got up late and we're like
struggling to get out the door and then
I'm like guys I'm sorry I got to install
the smoke detector right now and so I'm
like going sale stairs and getting the
drill so I could like drill cuz you got
to do the little you know drywall screws
and that kind of thing and I'm like
aren't you're gonna be a little bit
you're both gonna be a little bit late
for school that's the first thing that's
it I was just setting expectations
it's like dad has already failed yeah
but we got to have a smoke detector so I
do the smoke detector did a pretty good
job put it up there activated it we're
already a little bit late and then I'm
while I'm doing it I'm being very
dad-ish and I'm saying things like is
there anything that you guys could be
doing yeah I was like lock check the
freaking trash she can house the trash
trash need to be taken out and he like
he's like he goes and he's like no so
then I had to throw away the smoke
detector packaging and I go to the trash
the trash in the kitchen is completely
fool and I'm like you lied to me oh I
was like you said it was fine he was
like it is fine I was like are we seeing
the same trash can right now I was like
take it out
he said minute wasn't overflowing it
basically was it was within an inch of
the top I don't know what he thinks is
when it's ready so next thing I know so
I see Locke put the trash can trash bag
over his shoulder like a knapsack walked
out the door and then he comes back
upstairs and he's like cuz you have to
kind of go down the stairs in our front
warehouse to get down there he's like
again we're already where now we're like
twelve minutes late he says a trash bag
broke a caveman I go outside and I see
all he said at the bottom of the stairs
right when you get at the bottom of the
stairs and hit the driveway it looks
like one of those commercials where
they're like a Geico commercial where
the raccoons like alright we need some
really realistic looking trash like lots
of eggs lots of bananas throw some
blueberries in there maybe some old
coffee grounds like everywhere classic
trash wet did he keep walking with it it
just seemed like it because there was a
little piece of a carrot and a little
piece of a pea on the steps
oh so something was leaking there was a
hole some things got out and then the
whole thing came apart and all he did
was come up and say trash bag and of
course I'm already upset with myself and
I'm doing the thing that you do when
you're upset with yourself and you take
it out on your children if you're a good
dad and I was like what did you do wrong
like were you swinging it did it hit the
and the Shepherd was like well he
probably dragged it like Shepherd
shepherd giving his commentary it was
like that's why there's a pee on the
steps because he was dragging he's
forensic and so then we are I'm like
well fasting guys settle in because we
got to clean this up
so now we go down there and I'm like
getting paper towels and picking this
crap up and then sweeping it and then we
have to hose the whole thing
he also got onto the car I'm hosing the
car down and of course no one is saying
anything like once we start cleaning
there's just no conversation oh it's
just this is our lives and so they were
30 minutes late for school today
and we bonded Wow it's it's really all
your fault
the whole trashcan thing was your idea
it was it could just all those
blueberries and bananas and etc could
all just be that appeals could just be
sitting in the trash right now I'm glad
you made it I did I'm okay thanks for
thanks for worrying about me let's plug
mythical calm I changed into this shirt
even though my wife told me to wear
something else it's uh something wash is
what they call it they call that a what
do they call that crystal wash wash by a
girl named crystal yeah and then sent
out to you each one is one of a kind
mythical calm we got joggers hoodies
t-shirts crystal worked at the Belk
remember that up it uh Carrie tells me I
should give you a discount some thought
that I wanted to date her or she smelled
like every perfume combined Oh cause he
worked in the department that part of
the instant headache for me man I just
can't too much for me to the mythical
calm rip your boys all right can we get
into this that let's see where do I want
to start I want to start this story with
a word that never existed
that's what I'm calling it part one of
this story now my family particularly my
mom's side of the family my nanny her
mama had like nine brothers and sisters
and they have this own strange strain of
southern vocabulary and over the years
sometimes I'll say some words you be
like what was that or we'll get on
conversations about weird southern slang
and I'll always end up remembering words
that my nanny or particularly my
Vickey nannies the oldest of the
siblings and then Vicky is one of the
youngest siblings if not the youngest no
thing and they've lived together their
whole lives
nanny never drove Vicky would drive them
to work at the shirt factory where they
were inspected and folded shirts for
like decades that was Irwin right yeah
no no in Lillington awesome birthday
yeah yeah yeah where the you know I'm
where that Burger King is on the far
side of town yep
so they spent so much time together that
they perpetuate these words that became
very specific to like that family I'll
give you just a couple of examples now
both of these are related to poop
because it seems like they made a very
strong connection between your poop and
your health and of course there's people
who write books about this I think they
were on the cell coming irelia you know
got health but they wouldn't call it
poop they wouldn't they wouldn't say
[ __ ] of course they wouldn't he wouldn't
say that
they referred to poop as hockey and they
would say they would ask me when I would
go over there as a kid is saying do you
need to take a hockey is it that's so
weird well and I thought that it was a
really bad word I would like I was like
whoa that is like a expletive I would
never say that but did you make a
connection to the sport I knew what they
were talking about no no no but and I
knew it was also the word for a sport
but I can I you find I did not and I
still cannot make a correlation between
something related to the sport of hockey
and the sport of taking a crap what the
first thing that comes to mind for me is
the puck I guess if you every once in a
while you make one that's shaped like a
bug
I've never appending I've never I've
never pooped a puck you you've pooped
puck like things I've probably I've
pooped you've really looked like poop
really dark poops before how many puck
like never knew never puck colored poop
never that all right Oh have you ever
taken pepto
because pepto makes it black yeah yeah
but it doesn't make it hard like a puck
no that's good that's good point they
would always ask me yeah I it especially
if I like if I if I wasn't doing good or
I didn't if I wasn't hungry or some I
bet why do you need take a hockey and
then they would say you need to do a bad
job what would you do a bad job hold on
for and this is also a poop yes dude
this is why this is one of the reasons
that your anal retentive is because they
told you that pooping was a bad job and
first of all they told you that it was a
sport that in the south no one like
right you know before the Hurricanes
came it is so weird we hated hockey and
so it's like we didn't like it it's the
least favorite sport in a bad job and I
think things you had this relationship
with poop it was unhealthy from the
start and I would go out all your
family's fault I would go out in the
backyard now I like climb trees and hang
out in the backyard and then if I felt
like I needed to take a bad job do
number two I would just kind of squat
down and hold it and squeeze it in
because it was a bad job I wouldn't and
I don't know if they knew that I would
do that so then they were like really
harped on me about you have you taken a
hockey today do you need to hockey but
they put a lot of pressure on huh I
don't remember thinking putting any I
know to thinking about my poops until I
became like an adult man I mean this is
all a tangential yet very insightful
rabbit trail here my point at the moment
is just that they would use weird
terminology and there was another word
that did not have anything to do with
poop that they would they would use a
lot and the word was choir now I'm not
talking about the word queer even though
if you like especially not to let the
queer in like in modern parlance of our
times right the queue and lgbtq+ I'm not
I'm definitely not talking about that
you're talking about the traditional use
of the uses of the word queer which
would be unusual unusual right but queer
is kind of like a sister word to that
which they would use all the time it was
a specialized descriptor for someone who
was peculiar in a specifically picky or
opinionated way
matter of fact they would you know it if
I would if I would express concern or
disdain for something that they liked
like let's say Tomatoes be like don't be
so queer and so it could mean picky but
like very specifically peculiarly picky
so not like in tomatoes isn't the best
example but they would call me they
would call me queer a lot and so and you
you knew and I've told you tell me about
it and so my perspective on this word
you never heard of it well I'll say that
my perspective on a lot of the words
that your family used because it's
interesting because my family is very
southern you know but they come from
South Georgia and then we moved
eventually to North Carolina when I was
a kid but my parents are like from the
south grew up in the south you know mama
you've seen my mom when she was a guest
on GMM trying to we did a lie detector
thing yeah I'm very sorry she's a
southern woman but first of all she
didn't have like she talked like a
Southern woman and had a lot of
vocabulary that was kind of typical to
just people in the south but it was
nothing as specific as some of the words
that you use so my theory about a lot of
these words was that they seemed very
very specifically regional and then in
some cases my theory was specific to
your family right but but the word queer
I thought that you thought I thought
that you were like misremembering and
that there was a chance
they were your queer because it they
meant queer but they said it wrong may
up because it's a bit because it you
could substitute queer for queer and it
wouldn't be like if it would still kind
but still say it would still work well
as
specific yeah but because you've never
heard of it and we had this conversation
before and it was or multiple times but
it was basically like yeah yeah you have
to be mistaken you know we talked to
Stevie about this she was getting a kick
out of it but she had never heard of it
either you know she was in North
Carolina in fact no one that I could
talk to outside of my family had a had
heard of this word so I started to think
maybe it is something my family in fact
not even Google you can't find it all
they had heard of quare so I'm I'm
trying to convince I remember this
conversation with you and Stevie I'm
like it's it is it isn't an intentional
expression of something specific than
queer in the old definition and then
when I couldn't find it on Google I just
I had to resign to never being believed
and you know what Rhett it hurt it hurt
me man it's a weight that I carried okay
well that's a little queer of you I'll
come back to all this but look at look
at that is like a precursor like in
Fellowship of the Ring where it's like
Cate Blanchett gives the whole backstory
of the ring okay and you know that rings
gonna come back just in the next scene
it's a wonderful day in the Shire so
let's skip over to the Shire mmm I
really like to play that soundtrack but
that wouldn't work I'm going about my
happy business last week doing some work
I call my work happy business I don't
know if you ever noticed that as opposed
to a bad job what do you need to do
background do a bad job I'm a happy
business no it's not bad job as a bad
job it's like it's like it's like a
one-word base specifically a poop greg
III don't think Greg who works here is
constantly checking our Facebook
messages but apparently one came across
bless you one came across his desktop
and he forwarded the email to mean a lot
of the people in this room who have
stuff to do with your biscuits
it was an emotional Facebook message in
response to our first memories podcast
and it was written by and this is a long
queue I feel like you kind of just in
case I'll get some recap it was written
by the granddaughter of my babysitter
who her name isn't Betty but I will call
this granddaughter of my babies that are
Betty just to help tell the story okay
and I did get her permission to relay
this story to you guys today so I just
want to say all of that up front I'm
changing her name to Betty and she said
we could have this conversation that I
could read excerpts from our
correspondence now yeah as you were
saying I should recap what we said on
that first memories podcast now this
wasn't my first memory but once I
started talk about memories I started
talking about my babysitter when I was
in grade school and how she rolled my
arm up in her car window one day and how
she teased me about my mom not picking
me up there she don't come and I said
that I had separation anxiety that I
hadn't didn't tell anybody at the time
and she encouraged you to remove for try
to remove the wart that was on her
finger yeah and I think I proceeded to
call her a witch well you see but again
I was kind of I was joking I don't think
she was a witch but you know you
basically well I used her real name you
use her real name and I'm not gonna use
it right now I also use the term
demented right in the course of our
conversation and then we moved on not
only with the podcast but with the rest
of our lives until I get this message
and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna read a
big chunk of this message that some of
it I've taken out just to kind of keep
it moving but there's still a lot here
but I'm gonna read it here goes my
grandmother was and I have removed her
name Betty well no the granddaughters
name is Betty Oh
Betty wrote my grandmother was blank
please accept my deepest apologies if
for any reason you really think she was
doing something that appeared to be
demented I truly do not think she was
deliberately trying to harm torture hurt
make you feel uncomfortable I am sure
she did not want to cause you any trauma
I don't think my grandmother would
deliberately do anything to harm a child
now she very well would have said there
she don't come but I think it was her
way of passing time and was teasing you
but had she or I had realized it caused
you any pain it would have stopped it
actually breaks my heart because she
loved her linka dink she loved all her
kids in her care I hope that I can
resolve this in my mind as what a young
child sees versus what is or did take
place I'm hoping to that whatever the
reality is or was it is being overblown
and not being taken seriously she told
all the kids to keep their hands away
from the windows and doors of the
Chevrolet Monte Carlo and it was not a
Cadillac as you remember the particular
car had some of the fastest buttons once
she touched them I do remember that it
did come up fast I asked windows in that
Monte Carlo she cried about the fact
your little hand got caught in the
window and I remember her pretty nice on
it I am sorry you remember it as
thinking she meant to do it on purpose
and not as an accident because in your
story she did it and then she did it
again remembering it being a Cadillac
instead of what it actually was a
Chevrolet Monte Carlo can be seen as an
example of reality versus what we think
please don't get me wrong I'm not going
to justify it if you really think she
did hurt your on purpose
if she did I will say that was sickening
I just hope it is a difference in
memories again I apologize I'm sorry for
any trauma real or not that you went
through this has really bothered me to
the point I am crying hysterically and I
feel as if it is something I have to
personally do something about
I just don't know how to wrap my head
around it I have never heard of or have
known of any complaints against her and
this is so shocking to me this has
stunned me to my core Wow I read this
email and like even rereading it I'm
having the same feelings like I just
like I felt horrible in first I was like
wow I never really thought that like her
granddaughter would be listening
yeah that's not that's not the audience
I was thinking about when I shared this
story well not only that this I think
the message came like the day the
podcast came out it was some pretty
quick who listens regularly well I mean
it was there was a Facebook clip and I
don't know how you know Facebook clips
can really get around there was a
Facebook clip about this story right so
looks like no no it's not your votes
links but I actually suggest I was like
hey this is what maybe we should start
putting clips of your biscuits on
YouTube and maybe this is a better
candidate because it was like it's such
a memorable story right and that's how I
thought about it like an engaging story
from a past that was like kind of wild
and it gave window and how I thought as
a kid but like I just didn't think about
like my babysitter's family listening
how I was I was pretty shook up but you
know this isn't about me this is about
Betty and I mean I'll be honest my first
thought was this is just a Facebook
message I can just eat I can just ignore
it
this will go away I definitely don't
have to say anything and then I reread
it and I'm like oh my gosh she is she's
crying hysterically she's like she feels
horrible she's like questioning it's
like I gotta I gotta say something so I
wrote back I won't I won't read all of
it but I said Betty
well her name's not Betty I didn't
address her as I dress her with a real
name
yeah but I'm not doing that now which is
that was a just Betty I'm sorry that my
story has upset you and called into
question your memories of your
grandmother that was not my intention
and then I go on to share that I can I
can believe to her point that she didn't
she didn't mean any ill intent I told
her I told the story from the from the
perspective of the young child that I
was and I hold no ill will towards her
now as an adult
of course she she's passed away so I
hold no ill will towards her memory or
it might I just interject as someone who
is the kind of person who enjoys what in
the south we call messin with people
yeah yeah and I also I like messing with
kids the whole there she don't come
thing right yeah I would do that yeah
I'm saying now if I if I didn't found
out that oh he actually has separation
anxiety or snowbird then I would be like
oh but I'm just saying that like even as
you told the story in your childhood
version I even thought she was a witch
doing this more about the work part yeah
yeah like I know I even then witches
have warts and you were making some sort
of like I didn't I wasn't thinking
anything negative about her I was just
like this is just a woman with a sense
of humor and like you're remembering it
in a way that from the child's
perspective so yeah I know that some
people I didn't think that she took it
differently than that yeah I I didn't I
I didn't think that she did that on
purpose to like hurt me as deeply as it
did and there's no way she could have
known that because I didn't tell anybody
that again that was it was inside it was
an internal dialogue that but then the
part about the window I do think my
memory was that I think she did that on
purpose
right she's not rolling it down but
maybe it was when she tried she panicked
and was trying to roll it down and she
rolled it up more maybe you did have an
experience with getting your hand caught
in a Cadillac window to memory it wasn't
a Monte Carlo III went on to say as we
have discussed many times on our show
and in that particular episode as well
memories are not always reliable and
accurate and then I said I hope this can
put your mind at ease because I I hated
knowing that she was so upset and then I
said we are currently re editing this
show to censor all references to her
name it may take a few days for that
update to take effect in the system but
rest assured we've made the edits thank
you for reaching out again I'm sorry to
have caused you pain because I really
was I mean it was like you could tell
the emotion in the way that she wrote
her message it was like just kind of
like she was shaken to the core it was
something that she wrote it in a way
that she would say it to you you know is
a very like stream of consciousness oh
man but that was that was kind of tough
but I was like and when I wrote the
email to the I was like Greg give her
this message I also said like and I have
learned my lesson I'm not I'm not gonna
use real names and incriminating stories
well okay and you're gonna get into the
rest of the story in a second but I was
because she was so because you read this
to me
she was so shaken up that we actually I
started looking at the league the
legality around defamation oh you did
yeah
and started finding out whether or not
you could be sued I think for deface on
me Jacobs body language right now it I
think he was doing the same thing on his
office but you but you cannot you cannot
you can't defame a dead person because
what's at stake in defamation is
someone's reputation and a dead person
doesn't have a reputation so just from a
legal standpoint I don't you can say
whatever you want to about a dead person
they're people I have a reputation
that's pretty much all they've got
well that's them that is the ironic
thing as I was reading about it cuz I
was like yeah you think about someone's
legacy so you can ruin someone's legacy
but they don't have a living reputation
that if you just look at look at look on
the internet but the interesting thing
about it is that because I really got
into this and this is maybe I don't want
to be a lawyer but sometimes I started
looking into this and I realized maybe
that might this is what my dad was
because I get interested in this okay if
someone like okay you're right well what
about an estate like can you talk crap
about Elvis and then his his estate okay
right right no but what can happen is if
there's a defamation lawsuit that Appert
that a person has started before they
die and then they die their estate can
continue the defamation lawsuit but they
cannot start one that did not exist when
they were alive so you were telling up
and up and talk [ __ ] about somebody wait
until they died I think that's that's
the bill and that's why tell-all
biographies come out right when somebody
dies so you've got you think they've sat
they've written it in there's one
hundred percent people are sitting on
all these scandalous stories and then
somebody dies and you got two things a
there in the news so you can jump on
that this seems like EB uh I've got all
kinds of things written about you I've
got my whole tell-all expose out link
yeah and I don't know what I'm gonna
call it yet but maybe Lincoln City
Lincoln again zinc it and I'm so ready
to release it if I all of you just just
know that that's coming your reputation
will be in tatters well you know what
when you die first I'm gonna dig it up
I'm gonna change my name to your name
and release it so everything you write
about me will actually be about you I
don't know if that'll be believable
believable based on the content but
because we're different heights okay
you're all you're gonna change although
I listed your height so I didn't feel I
felt like it was a
the the momentum of I don't know my
initial reaction is like right the the
email and I don't know if you'd call it
an apology but I well there I was sorry
that my story had hurt her and called in
a question how she viewed her
grandmother that wasn't I did apologize
for that and I was sorry for that but
you know it's not like you're
apologizing to somebody's face and you
know how they respond and you feel you
can either feel relief or like can
clarify or whatever and this is all on
facebook messenger not messenger but the
Facebook email thingy but thank goodness
she did respond and respond she'd thank
goodness on so many levels that she
responded can I just read her response
to you yes because I didn't I didn't
know I didn't know how I couldn't have
predicted how she would respond it's
like well that's not you know I mean and
now I'm just angry and are you saying
that you didn't mean any of it and why
did you say it and yeah I don't know I
was like I was apprehensive
here's her response thank you so very
much for your response
I'm so very relieved to have an
understanding about this thank you for
reaching out to me so that I can now see
how we both could have been seeing this
as just a difference of memories and the
way we look at things
I accept your apology wholeheartedly and
thank you for what you are doing it
feels good to be to clear something up
man to be to be forgiven for something
being from the creek and growing up
there as well as having family and
friends there it was concerning that her
name was out there and associated with
being demented I think that was the
biggest issue for me and my family and
then it goes further get ready
she goes on to say again I will say she
as well as most of us has or have some
peculiar
or queer or different ways of thinking
and doing but to now no she didn't
intentionally harm you brings me comfort
and there you have it the the big old
B's story to this here's the sentence
right here don't you put it in quotes
again I I will say she as well as most
of us has or have some peculiar or in
quotes q you a ar e end quote or
different kill your queer or thinking in
doing she used the word in a sentence
she in the same sentence define the word
she spelled the word with an A in it you
were really holding on to this she put
it in quotes undeniable it exists Claire
exists we'll come back to that she is
not done she continues I've been late to
the rhett and Link GMM party but I've
enjoyed watching and listening to the
quote hometown boys that have made it as
you have
exclamation point hmm what's happening
here in fact I asked and received from
my sister a copy of the lost cause of
the Bleak Creek for Christmas I had just
started the book on Sunday and then I
saw your post about my grandmother and
then I was disillusioned that stop
reading immediately if she said the book
she says I will keep reading now as well
as keeping watching and cheering for
that sweet cute little feller that we
called linka Dean she was a fan she had
the book I will
the book out of the toilet let it air
dry and you find your book did you
hockey the novel Lincoln dad you do a
bad job in that novel thank you again
and I very much appreciate your
answering my message and especially that
you would be willing to remove her name
oh man I have never been so relieved to
have an apology accepted and trust me
I've apologized a lot in my life
probably still not as much as I should
have but to feel that amount of relief
and by the way I'm not done with her
message but at this point in the message
to fill that amount of relief I was so
glad that I did respond but then also to
feel the elation and validation that
this word was not just in my family's
twisted microcosm of vocabulary and
extended to at least other people in the
county it extended out a little bit a
little bit I I find it interesting that
you feel so vindicated when I don't
really think much has changed it's still
something that of some people you didn't
believe me man you don't believe me well
we'll wait till we get to the end I
still have a theory about this word but
I don't want to upset you at this point
all right so then she keeps writing I'm
also thankful for you and Rhett sharing
your lost years and how you have evolved
oh my gosh she's been listening to the
podcast it is very interesting to me to
see your transition from religion I have
questioned Christianity the Bible the
fax and other things myself I think many
have I'm impressed by your candor and
knowledge I have relatives and friends
who are LGBTQ and have always been leery
of religious bigots and the
cherry-picking that some used to keep
their bigotry going and or using it as
an excuse to not be a good person all of
a sudden she's going oh living and
growing up in the Bible Belt is
challenging and with the political BS
with the wannabe dictator it's
challenging on a daily basis now
political thing like you you wouldn't
think that the Venn diagram of people
who use the word queer and people who
would say the things that she's saying
there doesn't seem like there may be
just one person if that and that I am
NOT reading her those cross over her
tirade about what her her hot take on
our Lost years and I'm not reading this
to be self aggrandizing I'm reading it
to make that point Rhett that people who
use queer are thoughtful people now
whether you disagree with her point of
view that's that's that's not the point
I'm making but she's got a strong one
she's got a strong point of view and it
is thoughtful and there's heart in it
living and growing yeah okay so I can't
believe how some of the most educated
people are truly shameful and can't get
their past can't get past their own
biases and beliefs
looking forward to more from you and
Rhett okay thanks again and please know
that there is and are no hard feelings
on my part
FS good very next sentence we had snow
here and now she's going into the way
this is this this message is a journey
unlike any Facebook message anyone has
ever received she wasn't just talking
about the weather though we had snow
here and most all are a little giddy
about it but your response to me tops
that it is enter than snow it snows not
every three years in February and like
is a big deal but she said that my
response made her it topped that made
her giddy and then she says it has made
me a better person and giving me peace
to know that you took the time to read
my message and in kind to respond you
didn't have to and that's what makes you
a great and decent person i'ma cry and
then she says go rock on now because I
am amazing I can't
she her name Betty
your name's not Betty you are amazing
and you have made me a better person
what who what are you doing saying that
I made you a better person I did
something I didn't take your feelings
into account and I put this thing out
there on the internet just because I you
know in it seemed confessional but
honestly it was mostly just for kicks
and I think as I told the story I was
like oh this did have an impact on me a
lot of times on this podcast I say
something just to get it out there and I
don't even know what I mean to myself
but I know quite a lot it does doesn't
it
yet she's saying that like this made her
a better person like it I'm floored by
that I mean I did the shoe is to me is
on the other foot big time and again
this thing enriching and enriching
interaction with somebody especially one
in which there was a misunderstanding or
conflict and to see that resolved I can
see her point but yeah it's more than
well it was the she was the she what's
the better person but yeah yeah she was
you extended an olive branch I and she
graciously accepted it and that because
it's like even when you when you
apologize you feel like this is gonna be
picked apart you know and I don't want
to get on a soapbox here but like
there's that's what happens in public
I'll inch on i'll inch on to the soap
box that like if somebody sincerely
apologizes it's like I know what it
feels like to be sorry and then not know
exactly the right words to say you know
and it's it feels good when you
sincerely empathize with pain you've
caused and you're sorry for it and then
somebody has a they have a gracious
response because I I think because of
the culture we're in I was I had a
heightened anxiety
and at first that was part of my
knee-jerk response to say hi you know
what we can we can set the Facebook
thing so she can't even see that we read
this
so there's cope ability that like okay
she doesn't even have to know that we
saw it or that I saw it and so I didn't
he a reasonable conclusion could be that
we didn't see it not that I actively
didn't respond because responding opens
you up to a whole new level of criticism
and to be clear we don't we don't we
don't respond to every complaint and
every concern because we get a lot of
them it's a regular basis for all kinds
of things that people have been offended
by yeah yep and we sometimes it feels
like this but this this felt different
it was well it reasons that you've
already caught it was very it was it was
very deeply personal and I just couldn't
you know I'm not Tooting my own horn I'm
saying that like I thought about not
saying anything yeah yeah I couldn't so
I went forward and then it was but it's
to me it's not okay what what have I
learned in this process well before you
move on cuz I think is my last I think
you're making a really good point about
the apology thing because man I've seen
it so many times in the past few years
somebody does something that's
legitimately upsetting to people and a
lot of times it might be something that
was unintentional or just sort of
misguided and then they apologize they
make an apology video on YouTube they do
the apology tweet where you just take
your notes app and you write something
and you put it on your Twitter which it
doesn't mean this is just a part of
culture at this point people who have
any sort of following or you know are
public figures in any way at times will
probably have to apologize and it is a
guarantee that a certain percentage of
the audience will see that the apology
is an inadequate that they will get and
try to figure out people's motivations
for the apology oh you're trying to
protect this but this is what you think
and if you really were sorry this is
what you would say and it's just like it
is just a
part of culture to have somebody do
something and then apologize and then be
jumped on for apologizing not in the
right way now it makes it really
difficult to even want to apologize now
there is a legitimate assessment of an
apology yes like we're not saying that
you shouldn't assess someone's apology
to see if it's an a real apology yeah
yeah and that if that if it's a
apologizing for the the actual
infraction right you know say we and and
and we haven't had to do that personally
I guess I'm just saying that when I
because we are public figures who
invariably or you know inevitably will
offend already have and will continue to
accidentally or whatever offend people
and then at some point the that offense
may reach a threshold where we feel like
we have to apologize when I see it
happening because it's I can I can
relate to just all the anguish that
someone is true ah I shouldn't have said
that or I should have done that now I
got to figure out how to craft this in a
way that will make it see you know it's
just I have sympathy for people in that
position but I'm not saying that people
should do be able to do what they want
to in that apologize I'm just saying
that the dynamic of apologizing
sincerely and being accused of it being
insincere is just something that it's
just a troublesome part of this the way
our culture works right now in my house
I tried you know I hope that we set up
an expectation of having to apologize
and then and then a practice of
forgiving each other you know I think
that is a good practice because it
demanding that you never do anything
worth apologizing for or then Apollo
then apologies become admitting not just
what you did wrong but like that you're
a bad person I think why we all do
things that we need to apologize for but
it's so it's not a it shouldn't be a
double failure when you apologize it
should be it should actually be a
victory
if it's a true a true apology should be
a victory not a second defeat yeah so
what what are my takeaways from this
experience I don't you know I'm gonna
really think twice before I use real
names I've always gotten a kick out of
using real names even matter of fact in
that same first memories episode my and
I will use the real name because we got
his permission for the tour of
mythicality my first best friend Brad
McDonald actually emailed me and you
know that was he was the one who did the
orange hockey yep
bright orange he said he was laughing
and he was like I met my first memory is
you making me put my finger in the in
the light socket
shock you myself so you get but I was
like people are listening and and thanks
to Facebook if nothing else like things
get around if people are mentioned it's
gonna get to them and I need to
appreciate that a little bit more and so
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to be a lot more
sensitive just using real names because
again I'm sharing my perspective it's
like shooting from the hip a lot of
times but that's that's one thing that I
just gotta I got to get better about I
think the second thing is what we
already talked about about apologies and
then you know you know this is not what
made it all worth it but boy it's a
sweet sweet silver lining to this story
that queer came into it
the thing I didn't tell you was before I
read her response which you used the
term queer again it was in a forwarded
email from Greg and Stevie was on the
thread and so the first thing that I
read like it pulled up on my phone you
can see the first few lines of an email
and it was from Stevie and it said
ladies and gentlemen I think we have
seen our very first occurrence of queer
in the wild and you have never seen me
clamor to put the face ID and open up an
email as when I read that from Stevie
I'm like what what did she say
now it wasn't just as she accept my
apology but how she used queer does she
use it right did she spell it right
again for it's a sweet sweet silver it's
so validating man so eat it Rhett I
don't think I've got to eat anything
because I still think that the the
origin of the word is a bastardization
of the word queer I just think okay I
agree with it I just think most likely
that the circle of people who do that is
a little bit bigger than your family and
includes your babysitter's family so I'm
glad you feel vindicated and I know what
she was queer yeah my babysitter was
choir I mean how else do you get
do you dare someone to pull up yank a
ward off your finger that's a queer
thing to do that's a queer thing to do
and I love her for it I got a kick out
of it people people were appalled but
like I shared it for the because it was
wild man when I told Christine this
whole story and I'm I sat her down her
in Lando down we were sitting outside
drinking some coffee
and whatever the way that you're doing
the way that you're talking today is
like you're purposely saying things that
are people take [ __ ] outside drinking
some coffee I asked him to stick his
finger in the lights are you doing that
on Burma no I'm just talking oh man I
said her day I I gave her in Lando this
podcast like I made him sit through the
whole thing and I read all of it and at
the very end when I guess allowed them
to get a word in edgewise the first
thing Christie said was I now have the
perfect word for you you are queer yeah
and I was like date nanny and Vicki
called me that my whole young life yeah
it's it's and I wear it as a badge of
honor you're queer just yourself be if
quare is you
but given the fact that it's cut it's
sort of close don't do it to queal
whatever you're trying to do right now
no not I'm just saying that don't take
this from me I think that it could
people could again you might end up
doing something that then you have to
then apologize for you know like you
can't get it if you wanted to have
teacher this is I'm here and I'm choir
okay like you can't take that you can't
take that because that is already a
thing that people who are actually
identify as queer oh say and they use it
in them in the modern didn't use modern
values
I didn't say how did you just say where
oh and I'm just saying the next thing
that might come out of your mouth is I'm
here and I'm quite oh no and I'm just
saying that maybe that is not the path
for you I don't want to get I don't want
to infringe like don't get a tattoo that
says queer for yourself you know no
that's okay that's that's not infringing
are you saying you okay I think what I'm
saying is is I think that queer is an
appropriation and so now you're gonna be
guilty holding obligation and that then
you got to apologize for that on the
Internet and then people are gonna say
that your apology isn't sincere I'm just
looking out for you as your buddy
that's your slightly less queer buddy
you seem you seemed pretty clear right
now you're being real queer we've dug a
little hole at this point I again I want
to thank your name's not Betty one more
time for being so gracious in your
response and I just got the and I you
know I told her I told her this in my
response I just got the biggest kick out
of out of the whole thing and then she
went on to say that she when she
originally got worked up it was she had
watched the Facebook clip but then she
went back after my response and she
listened to the whole episode and within
the context of the whole episode it
actually cleared some of it up but I
told her I wanted to talk about queer
and she said I have a very pronounced
southern accent and I've always heard
the use of queer although I am pretty
sure it was in some cases misused for
queer and I am still guilty of saying
don't be so queer lol or more like ain't
no need of being so damn Choir about it
that's what she says like being very
persnickety about something that doesn't
matter because you're just weird
mm-hmm that's me yes it is yeah
she's in any way you can use our
conversations hopefully it will allow a
dialogue and a better understanding for
others if you need me to sign something
let me know thanks sorry about the emoji
I can't figure out how to remove it just
like it was the the winky face with the
tongue hold on which is that's what you
do we are we're kindred spirits but oh
yeah it's not bad
that's the weed emoji that you do all
the time what no need to remove that
next time I go home I got a I got a I
got a hang out with her name's not Betty
we got it we got AK wear it up have a
queer convention well if I get if I if
it's me and her name's not Betty if I
can get to other people who are queer
we're square
for square you think you can find four
people who use the term queer well you
know what if you are from the south or
from me know from anywhere if you're a
person and you have used the term queer
in the the sense that we have described
it
hashtag ear biscuit us these please I
would love every week on this podcast to
read one more person who validates my
use of the word queer and also validates
me being queer because I would I would
definitely I would think that you the
further the radius extends from that
part of Harnett County out yeah the more
validated you should feel so if there's
somebody I don't know if I can feel more
validated so somebody like move to
Alaska and took queer with
oh yeah if it's getting out there he's a
big race I think we're doing it now I
don't know if we should people tell Mike
we're in hockey I I just think again for
reasons I just talked about I think it
it could be misunderstood so easily that
I don't necessarily think we should be
proponents of you the usage of the word
queer the power of words exactly
baby rec I got it is it my rec timers it
rests it's yours I would just like to
recommend that she climb a tree
especially if you're not a tree climbing
age I recommend that you climb a tree
you don't drop what you're doing to do
it but next time you see a tree a climb
above tree do it interesting little
quare of you thanks for letting me tell
that that story you need me to go help
you clean up the rest of your trash nope
host it down already okay good to go
I will speak at you next week stake
where to watch more ear biscuits click
on the playlist on the right to watch
the previous episode of your biscuits
click on the playlist to the left and
don't forget to click on the circular
icon to subscribe if you prefer to
listen to this podcast it's available on
all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]